Je vais vous montrer comment faire.
J'ai capturé quelques moustiques dehors
et contrairement à Bill Gates, je ne vais pas les relâcher.
(Rires)
Mais je vais vous montrer comment les enregistrer.
Vous les faites voler ainsi,
d'abord un essai,
oui, je les entends.
Vous prenez votre téléphone, qui est équipé d'un micro.
Ce micro est super puissant,
même sur un simple portable,
et c'est suffisant pour enregistrer la signature.
Je n'ai plus le temps
donc je vais vous passer l'enregistrement que j'ai fait hier.
(Bourdonnement)
C'est le son charmant que vous avez déjà tous entendu,
et que vous adorez.
Dans notre contexte,
enregistrer ces sons avec un portable
nous permet de cartographier les espèces de moustiques.
Avec ce simple téléphone,
on a cartographié la plus grande banque de données acoustiques
qui contient 20 à 25 espèces de moustiques vecteurs de pathogènes.
Avec ça et l'apprentissage automatique,
et vos données,
on peut identifier et déterminer
l'espèce de moustique que vous avez analysée.
Ça s'appelle Abuzz, et si vous voulez participer,
visitez le site Internet.
Pour conclure,
une chose qui me tient particulièrement à cœur.
Un de nos défis majeurs est que nous sommes face à de terribles problèmes :
il y a un milliard de gens sans soins de santé,
le changement climatique, la perte de la biodiversité,
la liste est longue.
On espère que la science apportera des réponses.
Mais avant de quitter la salle de conférence,
j'aimerais que vous promettiez une chose.
Nous allons rendre la science accessible,
pas uniquement à ceux qui en ont les moyens,
mais aussi aux milliards qui ne les ont pas.
Faisons de la science et de l'éducation scientifique un droit de l'Homme.
Quand on transmet la sensation euphorique de la découverte
à un autre enfant,
on l'arme pour faire partie de la génération suivante
qui pourra résoudre tous ces problèmes.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)